how many trees are there in a forest
what about a country how about in the
whole world the answer we now know is
that our planet is home to 3.3 04
trillion trees that's actually almost
eight times more than we thought as
previous estimates only based on
satellite pictures but now we have to
wait and not just on how much land is
covered in forest but how dense those
forests are as well
measurements were collected by thousands
of people out counting trees in forests
all over the world
the average density of trees at each
location is represented by the height of
a green light some of the dentist area
that these subarctic forests we can find
a treat every square meter that almost
half of all our trees and found growing
in the vast tropical and subtropical
forests all this data is going to help
our understanding of where endangered
species might be able to live how water
recycling ecosystem or how much carbon
dioxide being absorbed from the
atmosphere it also helps us work out
what we'll be doing to preserve and
replenish our planet's forests because
even accounting for new growth we
currently losing about 10 billion trees
a year at the moment there are about 400
trees every person on earth are
disappearing at a rate of one point four
trees and every single year
keep going at this rate walk in the
woods will soon become a lot trickier
thousands of years ago before human
civilization took hold the F had almost
twice as many trees as it does now most
of Europe example was one big forest
groups all over the world are working on
planting trees and restoring natural
habitat
this new data will make their targets
more accurate and it will certainly
change our fundamental understanding of
our planet we now know we share with 3.1
04 trillion trees